tell me a little bit about the team that
you're building here and why an engineer
would want to come and work at tapad
well that's an interesting question and
of course it's uh it's uh well it's not
a hard one to answer actually we're
looking for
to build a team with really really
skilled engineers uh both on the
technical side but also on the on the
team dynamics
side we're looking for people
that
have already a proven track record
and that can come in
get a problem presented to them and then
start working on it with us
and solving them
if you want to attract
really good developers then you
typically have to
give them something that is interesting
and scala has no doubt about it caused a
lot of interest in in the java community
and also in other
language communities and
being slightly esoteric is a good it's a
good thing and
if you want to attract people yeah
that's an interesting strategy and you
have a unique perspective on
um repeatable jobs versus
jobs that require a lot of brain power
tell me about something we have a
slightly
sure egalitarian is the right word here
but we we don't we don't hire first-rate
and second-rate programmers here
developers we we expect everybody to
perform on the same level and this also
means that we're not going to have
people coming in that have to do all the
mundane tasks we we want to make sure
that we have a team that will
everybody has to do simple things every
now and then but
if the simple thing is something is
that's repeatable then it should be
automated instead of spending time on
that the next time so we automate the
simple and we spend our our
brainpower on solving the harder and
more interesting problems
there will always be a balance between
really fun stuff and then the more well
most things are fun actually but uh i
mean we can't ever guarantee that every
single day will be super exciting that's
great but
i think when you put
a lot of engineers
really really good ones into the same
room they will always come up with
really really good solutions and they
will be able to implement them in a
fraction of the time that
a
huge team of
less skilled developers would so and
that's our kind of founding principle
that applies to the whole organization
not only the development engineering
team this applies to the whole company
so you will work with peers in product
management and in sales and that are
really awesome people so any anything
else that's awesome about tapad that we
missed that you want to talk about
i think we've covered a lot
i'm sure we have missed a lot
i think the key takeaway here is
the team we're building
and the fun we are having
everybody's pulling in the same
direction
nobody's slacking doesn't mean we're
working people 24 7 here actually that's
one of my uh
one of my principles is actually that i
want people to have a
sustained pace all along we don't we
don't burn them in light at all all
every time we expect people to pull
through if they say we're in a tough
spot but
no the team the team is um
also outside engineering that's
important everybody here is uh pleasant
to work with yeah great awesome
well thanks for chatting with us this
has been really great thank you yeah i
appreciate it